-Il est le challenger qui s'impose
là où on ne l'attend pas forcément,
que ce soit comme maire d'Ajaccio,
comme député,
ou aujourd'hui comme président
du groupe Horizons à l'Assemblée,
mon invité a toujours déjoué
les pronostics.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Laurent Marcangeli.
-Bonjour.
-Vous faites partie des députés
qui ont eu une adolescence
différente.
Vous n'aviez pas de posters
de chanteurs ou d'acteurs de cinéma,
mais c'était plutôt Jacques Chirac
et le général de Gaulle.
-Il y avait pas que ça.
Il y avait des joueurs de foot
et des top models,
mais il est vrai que...
-Votre père raconte,
en tout cas,
qu'il trouvait ça étonnant.
-Il avait été très étonné,
car personne ne s'intéressait
assez à la politique
pour aller jusque-là.
A l'adolescence,
j'ai été pris de passion
pour la politique
et je supportais Jacques Chirac,
candidat à la présidence
de la République.
-La présidentielle de 1995 a fait
l'objet d'un déclic chez vous.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a passionné
dans la campagne présidentielle
de Jacques Chirac ?
-Sa volonté.
-C'est pas tant le combat d'idées,
c'est plutôt l'histoire
de cet homme, donné battu,
ce côté presque romanesque ?
-J'ai été séduit par son discours
sur la fracture sociale.
-Il y avait cet aspect-là.
-On considérait qu'il y avait
un certain nombre
de problèmes dans le pays
qui n'avaient pas été réglés.
J'étais né en 1980,
juste avant
l'élection de François Mitterrand,
j'avais envie de changement.
Cet homme, ce physique,
cette stature,
et les difficultés
qu'il a rencontrées
pour arriver jusque-là
m'ont séduites.
-Le côté homme trahi
par ses proches.
-Le comte de Monte-Cristo,
comme je le dis souvent,
que je lisais, à l'époque.
C'était romanesque
et ça m'avait attiré.
-A la présidentielle suivante,
Jacques Chirac a tenu un meeting
dans votre propre ville, Ajaccio,
en 2002.
On va revoir un extrait
de son discours ce jour-là.
-La Corse
a besoin de bien d'autres choses
que d'un rafistolage
institutionnel
qui la placerait en marge
de la République.
La Corse et les Corses
ont besoin que soit mis
définitivement
un terme à la violence,
qui sape les fondements mêmes
de la paix sociale sur l'île.
-Si je vous remontre ces images,
c'est qu'elles vous rappellent
quelque chose.
Vous aviez 21 ans.
Vous étiez sur place
et vous êtes monté sur scène
et vous avez tenu un discours
devant Jacques Chirac.
C'est un moment qui vous a marqué ?
-On voit la photo.
-On vous voit avec lui.
-De lui parler à l'oreille,
ça m'a marqué.
C'était ma 1re expression
en public.
-En plus, devant celui qui était
un peu votre modèle.
-Quelqu'un qui m'avait
beaucoup inspiré,
qui était la raison pour laquelle
j'étais là.
On m'avait fait la proposition
d'ouvrir ce meeting.
C'est émouvant,
de revoir ces images,
car il y avait du monde,
il y avait un chapiteau
qui avait été fait exprès pour.
Je me suis retrouvé, à 21 ans,
devant plusieurs milliers
de personnes, chez moi,
pour parler de cette campagne
présidentielle
si particulière de 2002,
avec Jacques Chirac au 1er rang.
-Et avec un ancien député
qui vous a dit :
"Vous serez député, un jour."
C'est ça ?
-Oui, mon prédécesseur.
-Il vous a repéré.
-Oui. Il avait été député
de la 1re circonscription
de la Corse-du-Sud.
Il m'a dit :
"Vous serez député, un jour."
Je lui avais répondu :
"Il va falloir
que je fasse mes preuves avant,
"que j'aie quelques diplômes."
Il m'a dit :
"Non, vous serez député."
-Les valeurs gaullistes
vous ont séduit.
A 16 ans,
vous avez pris votre carte au RPR,
alors que vos parents
votaient plutôt
pour les nationalistes corses.
La cause nationaliste
vous a-t-elle tenté, à un moment ?
Vous vous êtes posé la question ?
-Non, car au début
de mon engagement, à 15 ans,
j'ai tout de suite été happé
par les idées portées
par la droite gaulliste,
mais je suis corse.
Ca, c'est indissociable
de mon identité.
J'ai pas besoin d'être nationaliste
pour l'être plus que d'autres.
-C'est compliqué, la politique
en Corse, quand on ne l'est pas ?
Vous êtes le seul député
non-nationaliste, en Corse.
-Oui.
Vous savez, ce sont des cycles.
Les nationalistes ont mis des années
avant de réussir à avoir
un seul élu,
ne serait-ce que dans une mairie,
car ils étaient rejetés
par la population,
il y a eu des évolutions,
du changement
dans la vie politique corse.
Face aux électrices
et aux électeurs,
ça se passe plutôt bien pour moi,
peut-être parce que les discours
que je tiens
et les actes qui sont les miens
conviennent,
qu'il n'y a pas besoin
d'être nationaliste pour être élu
et accepté par la population.
-Au lycée,
on vous surnommait "le maire".
Vous avez déjà l'ambition
de devenir maire d'Ajaccio ?
-J'avais dit que je voulais
être maire de la ville un jour,
car c'est une ville qui m'est chère,
que j'aime.
Personne ne pensait véritablement
que j'allais avoir
cette forme de constance
dans l'engagement
et que ça allait arriver.
-On va raconter votre parcours.
Ca s'est fait étape par étape,
mais vous y êtes arrivé.
Vous êtes d'abord devenu député,
en 2012.
Dès l'âge de 20 ans,
vous vous êtes présenté
aux municipales
sur la liste du maire
qui s'appelait lui aussi
Marcangeli.
Il n'est pas de votre famille,
ou en tout cas, éloigné.
-C'était un petit-cousin.
Nous ne nous sommes connus
que dans le cadre
de la vie politique,
puisqu'il avait un accord
avec le RPR,
et moi, j'étais candidat
en tant que membre du RPR...
J'avais beaucoup de cheveux.
Le temps passe.
J'étais au RPR,
j'étais le benjamin
de cette liste.
Ca se voit, j'étais assez jeune.
Je n'avais que 20 ans.
-6 ans plus tard,
vous avez été élu dans l'opposition.
Vous étiez le chef de l'opposition.
Vous avez réuni un peu
la droite d'Ajaccio,
qui était assez divisée,
et en 2014,
vous avez été élu maire.
On sent la force
de votre détermination
pour atteindre vos objectifs.
-Je crois qu'on pouvait avoir
n'importe quel candidat,
de n'importe quelle tendance
qu'il soit.
Lorsque vous voulez la victoire,
il faut une ferme détermination.
Ca ne vient pas seul.
Surtout quand vous avez
une opinion partagée.
Le maire était installé
depuis 13 ans.
Les gens sont assez rétifs
au changement.
Lorsqu'on change de maire
alors que le sortant est candidat,
c'est assez rare.
C'est ce qui s'est passé en 2014
à Ajaccio.
-Vous dites que vous n'avez pleuré
que deux fois, en politique :
le jour où vous avez été élu maire,
et le jour où vous avez dû renoncer
à votre mandat
parce que vous aviez été élu député,
réélu en 2022.
Si vous étiez si heureux
dans ce mandat de maire,
pourquoi l'avoir abandonné ?
-C'était le moment.
La situation exigeait
que je sois présent ici,
d'abord parce que la Corse
a vécu des moments difficiles,
notamment suite à l'agression
qui a coûté la vie à Yvan Colonna.
On a eu des scènes d'émeutes,
de violences très graves.
-Vous avez d'ailleurs rédigé
un rapport parlementaire.
-J'étais rapporteur
de la commission d'enquête.
Le lien se distendait
entre la République et la Corse,
à tel point qu'il fallait
qu'il y ait une voix forte,
dans la majorité présidentielle,
pour représenter la Corse.
C'est ce que j'essaye de faire.
-Vous êtes aussi
un éternel challenger.
Personne ne croyait en vos chances
aux législatives de 2012.
Vous avez été le seul
à reprendre un siège de député
à la gauche,
cette année-là.
En 2014, à Ajaccio,
vous étiez aussi le challenger
et vous vous êtes imposé.
En 2022, personne n'avait anticipé
que vous alliez devenir président
d'Horizons,
le parti d'Edouard Philippe.
Est-ce que vous adversaires
n'ont pas tendance
à vous sous-estimer ?
-Mal leur en prend,
visiblement.
-Pourquoi est-ce qu'ils vous
sous-estiment ?
-Je sais pas.
Ils me sous-estiment
de moins en moins.
On me voit plus venir,
chez moi et même ici.
Pour la présidence du groupe,
ça s'est passé
de manière très naturelle.
Les liens que j'entretiens
avec Edouard Philippe sont anciens.
Nous nous connaissons depuis 11 ans.
Ce sont des liens basés
sur l'amitié
et l'identité de point de vue.
Lorsque je me suis présenté
à cette élection interne,
ça s'est bien passé.
Les journalistes,
les commentateurs,
n'avaient pas forcément prévu
le scénario.
-On sent quelque chose de passionné
dans votre rapport à la politique.
Certains vous ont reproché
d'être un peu trop rude.
Vous le reconnaissiez
récemment dans une interview :
"A 31 ans, j'étais plus âpre et rude
"que maintenant.
"J'étais vraiment
dans une version 1.0,
"je n'étais pas encore
père de famille, ni marié."
Vous avez changé ?
-On change tous.
-Vous vous êtes calmé ? Assagi ?
-Bien sûr. Heureusement.
Heureusement qu'on s'assagit.
Ensuite,
on voit la difficulté des choses.
On les appréhende
d'une autre manière.
Surtout, on apprend à faire
avec les autres,
malgré les différences.
Parfois, j'étais plus cogneur,
plus puncheur.
Depuis un an, en tant que président
de groupe à l'Assemblée nationale,
ceux qui me fréquentent voient
que je suis un homme de dialogue,
ouvert, qui essaye de discuter
avec les autres,
qui essaye de respecter la fonction
et le cadre
dans lequel nous sommes :
l'Assemblée nationale.
-Il y a eu cet incident
relayé par le Canard enchaîné.
C'était au mois de février
de cette année.
Vous avez failli en venir aux mains
dans l'hémicycle,
avec le député LR Aurélien Pradié.
Le journal précise
que vous avez menacé
de lui casser les dents
et que les huissiers
ont dû intervenir.
Vous étiez prêt à faire
cela avec un député ?
-C'est exagéré.
Les huissiers
n'ont pas dû intervenir.
Ca s'est passé hors séance,
dans l'hémicycle mais en suspension.
Je ne dirai qu'une seule chose :
je suis très courtois,
je respecte énormément les autres,
et j'attends en retour
que les autres fassent de même
pour moi.
Ca n'a pas été le cas.
-Vous pouvez faire preuve de dureté,
y compris avec vos amis.
Jean-Jacques Ferrara,
votre suppléant à l'Assemblée
en 2012
vous a succédé comme député en 2017,
- puisque vous avez décidé
de rester maire d'Ajaccio -
mais en 2022,
vous lui avez repris le siège
de façon brutale.
Il y a pas de place pour l'amitié,
en politique ?
-Il y avait pas de place
pour prendre le risque
de perdre le siège.
Ce serait pas...
-Vous avez sacrifié une amitié.
C'était votre ami.
-Ca a été un des moments
les plus difficiles
de ma vie politique et personnelle,
parce qu'effectivement,
il y a pas que des liens politiques,
il y a aussi des liens personnels
qui se créent.
Un décision a été prise par moi,
mais qui n'a pas été prise
que par moi.
Il y a eu des discussions
avec d'autres.
Je n'agis pas
sur des coups de menton.
On n'était pas
sur de l'improvisation.
Il y avait eu une longue réflexion.
Je sais que j'ai fait du mal
à cet homme,
pour lequel j'ai vraiment
un profond respect,
mais je peux vous dire
avec certitude
- la difficulté de l'élection
qui a été la mienne -
que ça aurait été plus difficile
si ça avait été lui le candidat,
et qu'on n'aurait pas trois députés
autonomistes
élus à l'Assemblée nationale,
mais quatre.
-Votre trajectoire
suit celle d'Edouard Philippe.
Vous étiez engagés à droite,
vous avez soutenu Alain Juppé
pendant la primaire.
Vous avez rallié
Emmanuel Macron,
vous présidez le groupe Horizons
à l'Assemblée.
Est-ce que c'est pas un peu
comme avec Jacques Chirac ?
Est-ce que c'est pas une histoire
d'admiration, de respect ?
Vous avez besoin de ça
pour vous engager
derrière quelqu'un ?
-Si j'avais pas ce rapport
à Edouard Philippe,
ce rapport de fidélité,
de respect, d'admiration...
-Vous avez besoin d'admirer.
-J'ai besoin d'avoir confiance.
Je ne me range pas
sans cesse derrière quelqu'un.
Edouard Philippe est un homme
d'une très grande qualité,
tant d'un point de vue politique
qu'humain.
Ca compte pour moi.
-On va passer au quiz,
à présent, si vous le voulez bien.
Je commence une phrase et c'est vous
qui devez la compléter.
-OK.
-Un cliché sur les Corses
que je confirme...
-Susceptibles.
On est plutôt susceptibles.
-Un bon président de groupe
doit...
-Rassembler.
Il doit rassembler son groupe
derrière une ligne politique,
sur des textes
et sur une attitude à avoir
dans l'hémicycle
et même en dehors.
-Enfin :
en 2027, Edouard Philippe sera...
-Je ne sais pas.
-Elu président de la République ?
Vous le souhaitez ?
-Il a les qualités pour être un bon
président de la République,
comme il a été un bon Premier
ministre.
C'est une décision
qu'il doit prendre.
Le peuple français
décidera de qui sera
le chef de l'Etat en 2027.
-Merci d'être venu.
-Merci à vous.
Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA